You
Okay, hold on. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. My 3d. Oh
I tested everything before I started I tested everything this is my normal microphone
I was gonna whisper for some reason
My scarlet isn't working, so I'm trying to trouble you
But don't worry we're going to really get it
So just give me a moment. I
Apologize I literally have been ready for over an hour
Over an hour and then it decided I don't understand
I
Think my cat might have unblocked my scarlet from my computer hold on
Know it doesn't mean
I
Quiet
Okay
You might
You might hear my cat
Munching in the background
There's a lot of home you hear something
I'm going to commit
So
Okay
I
Don't
Kind of frustrated
Scarlet
I have to get like really in there, don't I?
Okay.
Hello, darlings.
Headphones are maxed.
Anyone as you go says you can't do me.
Okay.
Listen, I'm doing the post down here.
A little different because if you have a certain type of headphones, it may not work.
Alright, I'm on my keyboard.
I'm picking up the 3DO.
Okay.
I don't really care because I think this would be really funny.
It was really fun messing around with the settings on the VTube studio.
My neighbors are walking by and they're being very loud.
Good luck on your exam.
Alright, so I thank you.
Thank you for meeting me at the bar.
I'm happy that you followed directions in my Tinder message that I sent to you.
Because I sent you directions to this bar, don't worry that there's nobody else here.
I especially reserved it for the both of us.
I hope you don't mind what I don't know what a big bumping up is.
I generally don't know why it's doing that.
It's a big bar, but don't worry about anyone else.
It's just me and you.
I'm not rich.
Why do you think I'm bartending behind this bar right now?
I'm sorry I had to burp, but I didn't want to burp in your ear.
Unless you want me to.
But I'll be a professional madam for you tonight.
So my darling, what would you like to drink?
I can make you something.
If you're under the age of drinking, I can also make you a mocktail if you'd like.
I've been studying.
I'm going to forgive you a little bit.
I don't know, Mike.
You want chalky milk?
I can make you chalky milk.
I almost went out and bought Vanta because I realized I had an advantage in a decade.
Madam, your neck, don't worry about my neck.
I still got that, though.
And don't you forget it.
So you'd like some cold water.
You'd like dark coke, bloody Mary, strawberry milk.
So no head.
You'd like a bloody Mary, non-alcoholic.
Okay.
I have some lemonade and I have strawberry milk.
Get out of here.
I love oil.
What is wrong with you people?
Coke milk?
Yes.
I am milking.
Is there a buyer in the bar?
A shipping aid?
Yes, that can be arranged.
A bucket of soda.
Got some bleach.
Yeah, I got some bleach.
I also have some ammonia as well.
But yeah, don't worry that there's nobody else here.
It's just me and you tonight.
Okay, I'm going to take very good, very good care of you.
All right, let me get some ice.
Let's come right here.
All right, go.
I have some ice.
I have no idea.
I had to go to the back.
I had to step away for a moment.
In fact, I have to, hold on.
I have to step away.
I have to step away to do it.
Let me just, I can't part.
I'm trying really hard and I can't.
Because I know the microphone.
I'll pick it up.
But I also have some ice.
I have a nice setup.
Not long.
I am.
You know, I worked really hard.
I don't, hold on.
I'm like very tall.
Let me just, sorry.
Do you know how to share it?
Don't worry.
I run very fine establishments.
This is a bar within Wonderland Hotel.
So, one long island ice tea.
All right.
Coming right up, you know.
No one would want to like about ice though.
I like about ice.
Wow, that was like really, my teeth are sensitive.
I just, I live, I live dangerously.
I live very dangerously.
I can't go over like this or that.
We can ask for crushed ice, oh well.
That's the only type of ice we serve.
Hold on, let me crush it again for you.
There, I spit it right into the glass for you.
So, take a sip of that.
What do you mean?
You don't, you need a drink to go with it.
Okay, let me, let me pour you something then, hold on.
Okay.
My favorite ambiance is here.
It's my, it's my, my AC has made its arrival.
I'm so happy I put a towel down because it just smells drinkable.
Is it monster?
No, it's not do.
Because, you know, I got some out due because I'm going to mount it to you later.
So it's only fair.
The candle, oh god.
All right, here, let me come out from behind the bar.
Yeah, I teleported, whatever.
So, uh, the effects are really nice.
So, do you like my outfit?
Only, you know, a torso.
But do you like it?
Uh, don't mind that.
I'm not attached to my back.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry.
I was like, so ready to be so serious.
And then I was messing around with all this stuff this morning.
And I couldn't stop laughing.
I don't know why my fingers break.
There we go.
Does that work for you?
Do not be afraid.
You are safe with me, my dear.
My cat is climbing on my monitor.
Hold on.
My love, my god, please get down.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
She's like, was that only climbing over everything?
You guys like me, like, is this okay with you?
Like, what sucks is that when I turn to the side, it just disconnects.
Don't use it.
Okay.
I got a new cup, and it's like textured.
I'm very happy with it.
It makes really nice taps.
Do you want to sip out of my cup?
I'll give you a little taste, but only if you behave.
What do I have in my cup?
It's just tea.
It's just green tea in here, but I'm going to make myself a drink in a moment.
I'm going to show you tea.
I'll crouch over you when you can open your mouth.
Okay, if you say shippity toilet, I'm literally going to sick of my mods on you.
I swear to God.
We're not 12, and if you are 12, well, fuck are you here?
Get the fuck out of here, you little bitch.
I hope that you're having a good day today.
Thank you for swiping right on me, on my Tinder profile.
We're going to have this nightcap, and I guess maybe, but just maybe.
Hopefully I can keep my head on my shoulders.
You can come back to my place.
I don't know German, but cool story.
My head was attached in my pictures, but sometimes you kind of get a little crazy with it.
Sometimes it's good to lose your head.
Said it would be an old woman.
His maintenance still there.
Yeah, he's died up in my closet.
Did you hear his screams?
I stuffed my panties in his mouth.
I can make you guys whimper.
Do you want me to make you whimper?
Pop the bag.
Can you bag for a moment?
Are you tingling yet?
Do you want me to make you whimper?
I can give her a really strong drink.
In fact, actually, I need to pour myself a drink before I get to work on you.
I'm a little bad at it.
I'm going to grab some peach tea from the bird.
I don't know why.
I don't want to go in.
So there's three steps I have to take.
First step is pouring the peach tea.
I'm going to pour the peach tea.
I hope your hands are where they should be on your desk.
No, my ass is not as superior as Strone's.
So the second step is to pour the Jack Daniels.
I hope you're being good.
I don't know what happens if you're being bad.
Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
I just need to get a new candle burner.
Okay, so I'm going to get them to open up more.
I wish you could wake up over here and give me your clothes.
I wish you could open that candle burner.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
I'll be right back.
I think I bumped it.
It's my hand. It's my hand.
So I'll be brushing across the mic.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
I think I bumped it.
I got something special just for you.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
I think I bumped it.
I'm sorry my cat is eating in the background.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
I think I bumped it.
I don't know why.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
Don't hold your breath.
I don't know why.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
My head disconnected from my body.
Do you know how long it took me to actually, because like in order to have one of these outfits on, you have to make every layer transparent.
And I didn't know how many parts of my model that there were that my rigor had to cut up and animate.
I don't know why I'm struggling.
Yeah, because like, you know, all like all the Shibari ropes on my model, on my body are all individually cut.
They're all separate pieces along with the rings and the shadows are all separated.
I was like, and then I understood why Strani paid so much money.
Like, if you know anything about live 2D and rigging, I personally would look at the file and be like, no.
It only took me like 20 minutes to make everything transparent, but like so, yeah.
Shout out to fucking Nari.
Holy shit. Yeah, Nari's got it.
Truly, I would love to learn how to rig or make model art a really cool and lucrative skill to have.
Okay.
Okay, just come down easy sweetheart.
I know that was quite a ride.
Are you okay? Do you need me to get you anything?
Here, let me help you to the bathroom.
Just sit down and I'll get you cleaned up, okay?
Let me just run this nice, warm towel Oreo and wipe everything away from my darling.
Pissing all about yourself, handsome.
Oh, you're such a mess.
Oh, I've utterly destroyed you. I'm so sorry.
Oh, you would rather stand. I understand.
It might be hard for you to sit.
No shame in it.
There, you're all clean.
Did you want me to make you a bath instead?
I don't mind running you a bath.
You deserve it.
It worked so hard to clean me.
You did such a good job.
I don't know how to make running water noises.
I can't take my mic over to the sink.
Hold on, let me put my 3DO back on the stand.
I don't know.
Oh, you weren't the good boy. You were the best boy.
Just relax.
I'm going to pour some water down your back.
You have such beautiful hair.
You know, you also smell so good.
You smell like the aftermath of us.
You smell like the way it smells.
You don't even have enough water to tell you how wonderful you are.
You brought me so much pleasure.
You made me so happy.
I love you so much.
You always want what's best for me.
So let me take care of you right now.
Let me rinse your hair out my love.
I'm sorry, I don't have that much.
My supplement is just a little chat.
I'm close to being under 3K.
Hopefully after a week I know why I feel like we would have been past 5K by now.
But anyways, let me focus on you. You're all that matters to me right now.
I want to make sure that you feel safe and loved.
I have to make sure that I don't break too much.
You took it so well. You didn't break under the pressure. I'm so impressed with you.
I think you deserve a present.
You deserve the world, you know that right?
I think that means you need to be reminded more often that you are loved, that you are worth it.
That you're someone always there when you offer you love.
And that's me, because you're mine. You don't ever stop being mine.
You work so hard to please everybody, but you need to please yourself.
I want you to do something for yourself, because you deserve it.
You deserve happiness.
And I know the part of you, the part of you, takes the pain because I think that you're worth it.
You're loved. You mean so much to me.
I never feel like you have to punish yourself, all I do for pleasure.
Do you want me to tell you what I like about you?
I might never stop talking if I do.
I like how dedicated you are.
I love how warm you are.
You're so smart and intelligent and I can talk to you for hours.
You're welcome for my talk act.
I can't get my hands off of you.
Yes, you are so obedient. Another, you know, desired trait.
You need to cry then cry.
Let it out. It's not good to keep those things locked inside you.
Here, why don't you lay on my chest and just relax my thigh.
It's okay. Let it out.
Let it out.
I hope you realize how tough you are.
You can't do so much.
No matter how many times the world tries to break you.
You're still standing.
You're not going to ever forget that.
Do you want me to watch you?
Do I have you?
Yes, and I still have you.
No matter how strong you are.
Even though the world might seem harsh,
you can still find your way.
Always look like you're in somebody's happiness.
You can go and do anything you want to.
You can do anything you want to.
You may not think it. You may not have the confidence.
But that's the one thing I found out about that confidence in you.
You have accomplished so much.
What I want you to do when you go home after spending time with me.
I want you to look at the mirror and look at yourself.
I want you to do the right thing on five good things about you.
You're welcome.
I know what you're doing.
I'm glad that you thought you'd do that.
A lot of the things that bother us the most are like what you think you are.
I wish you had been strong and you didn't do so well.
You want me to come in five good things about you?
Hard work there.
You get up early morning and you take home the thing you might not want to be.
Some people might be simple by getting out of bed is a hard part.
You did it?
You probably, you know, had a choice in it.
You don't really do the time.
You probably completed the time.
You did the most simple as time and got through it.
Just don't take care of it.
You're also so very loving.
This is stuff like that.
I don't think I've experienced the type of love you've shown me before.
So intense.
So powerful.
So much love to you.
There's so much love to you.
So why don't you give it to yourself?
Shhh.
That's so good.
Just like that.
Think about other things too.
You don't know me at all.
It's going to be my fault.
Your safety.
And my love.
Even if it's just for tonight.
Don't cry.
Oh my sweet, don't cry.
Oh my floating fucking head.
Laugh, laugh at my floating head.
Do it now.
Laugh away.
I want you to be happy.
Wow.
My child.
Yeah, I can do aftercare too.
I'll insult you.
You won't take care of you.
Oh, please don't.
I'm a very empathetic person.
So I get it.
I can be soft dumb.
I can be hard dumb.
I can be a goofy dumb.
Which is mostly what I am.
Look at when I go to the side.
I was not doing it.
It was like these crazy stuff that was funny.
Happy hair end.
Okay, let's go to my bedroom.
After we've had a couple joints.
Go to my bedroom.
Okay, let's go to my bedroom.
Relax, I'm not leaving.
Sorry.
oh my god why am i so stupid
oh my god i'm gonna
there's a bit of a buzzing
no you're just like what bgm really loud
i hate it here i hate it here
oh it should be always this fun
yeah i don't know why i have like a weird second audio capture here let me remove this
can i
what is that where did that even come from weird
the cage gives you a bad feeling that's just where i hang my clothes from i just put hangers
there i don't know what you're talking about i just hang out my clothes i just took my clothes off
i mean like i put them in my closet instead of hanging them up there don't worry about it
okay let me switch
it's weird so like my neck is normally like a lot darker than this i had to change the
skin tone of my neck why do i look so white now i'm like white woman jump scare
let's one use book
okay let me move my i have so much shit on my desk does it sound good on my normal microphone
i don't know if you can hear that
she's surprised i'm a white woman
it's funny because people who know my pl because i was tan for my pl it's like why are you white
and i'm like i don't know don't worry i'm gonna get a tan like toggle eventually
she'd be flashbang i need to like bring back i thought you were black
i am mixed she's biracial she's biracial girl
good night if you're leaving good night yeah we're gonna i'm gonna do i want to be out of
office so bad
omg logic
that got me like i'm good
oh that got me
oh my god this shit i get rid of that shit i get rid of this shit oh
oh sorry they just sent me
managers posted in our um our discord like what our next collab is um
and the thumbnail looks so funny for i'm not gonna tell you what the collab is although i don't
what is the club i have to i can't remember i can't say this one is it next week i don't know um
but it doesn't it looks so funny of all of us in the thumbnail we just look goofy no i don't
like j Cole okay cool only good song hammer made was don't save her
oh
shit sorry um
i just looked at some strawny fan art
and that's some that's some alternative art there
wow we sound we
guacamole you want to pull close for me that's cute
that's funny i had like a drink menu up like i had this whole like i was like i'm gonna pretend
to talk about pouring drinks no i didn't do that that airplane in the background
maybe but it looks like an airplane did go overhead so it's also like my ac just loud as
fuck is there like a buzzing that usually isn't so high weird
oh the asmr got you sleepy go to bed go to bed i'm just no bunny now um go to go to eep
sounds like the wind oh that's my ac
i don't know how i'm ever gonna get rid of that without like
really like and it's weird like i copied all of the same settings in that i had on my pl account
for my mic and i never had that issue when suddenly on this i have the issue
i don't understand it i feel like it just doesn't work at all
sorry i'm like fucking with settings if you all means past life
everything i'm gonna get rid of one thing i don't know what you're talking about
what's wrong what's wrong with just something wrong i don't know anything that's wrong
i don't get rid of this i think it's my noise gate
hmm wait did that just fucking fix it
i'm gonna commit
i have a gorgeous neck oh thank you thank you so much i know i have a very gorgeous neck
my long nice giraffe-like neck are you against sharing my pl i will not share my pl because
uh she is she is hibernating she's she's committed she's not dead she's just she's sick so she's
getting a lot of rest i want to focus on shibi
what you don't you like my accent why my russian i don't know i don't know why i'm russian
she's not dead she's only sleeping
he's easy no easy oh shizzy
hello my name is um natalia
i am your russian wife this is our russian home a very standard russian furniture we have
the beautiful fireplace for the uh Siberian winters
i'm wearing a fur coat i'm very comfy i can uh if you want i can put my
fur coat on the ground and we can get shifty cringe
can i can
hit different i definitely hit harder i hit very hard how am i doing today i'm doing great
now that i'm hanging out with you accents are amazing oh i'm glad you like
my italian just sounds like racist because when i just sound like mario
it's me harder than stepfather i'm rep stop father you hate me but you will
i can't i can't do an italian now bippidy boppidy
because i also just sound like i'm from new york i'm cutting in and out now
i was peeking in and out
hmm
okay
it's a mea mario it's a mea shibi i'm here and i'm a queer it's pride month
it's
i'm sorry i just wrote something in chat
my brother my brother in christ i'm gonna i'm gonna clown on you for a second
hi allow me to introduce myself my name is fun time freddy you should go fast burn
i'm one of the legendary majin fazbear from fnaf at z zunokai a crossover of fnaf and all anime
it's nice tell me to you
konichiwa
gregory
grog Harry
croc bulls i wasn't croc
You're my superstar you need to vent Gregory I can't go that deep though Gregory
now we get into the real role play Gregory my ass is so fat when I walk it
claps and alerts all the robots Cusco the poison made for Cusco the Cusco poison
it's all common together hide inside me Gregory come inside come inside me
actually no I'd have to listen to her voice to do it the poison made
specifically to kill Cusco yes I did know they didn't have a script for that
movie I recently I think I started like a Twitter thread about that I was like
yo Gregory you'll get inside my chest a hot won't you Gregory
a llama he's supposed to be dead now yeah I'd have to listen to her voice like
she's like okay did I get anything I spilled a little bit stuff in my desk
but looks like it just stayed on the towel
man oh I want to watch that I haven't seen the Emperor's new groove in such a
long time okay let me oh my shit go this friend I got my cat from color
easel oh that's cute oh my shit on my cables are tangled because my 3d I think
I got to piss again I got a piece I got a text I got a piece I'm totally fucking
bugging he's real fit he's really hot we're also gonna watch along Love Island
just saying oh by the way how does it sound because I is it bad I don't know
if it's Gregory got a piss go piss girl XOXO go piss girl I still have these
things I think I'm gonna keep these these are good for like triggers and shit it
was like the packaging that came along with the globes I shouldn't have thrown
away the box for the globes it's kind of dumb of me it is what it is press P to
piss pissing pissing turn left then piss open your mouth
aww RIP to wage-sleeping why are you guys saying aww I was kidding I was kidding
at the light past the 7-eleven piss now I'm thirsty where's my meal pissing at
next exit in 2.2 miles tazin a motherfucker
re-calculating re-calculating turn left throw that ass back
time and oh yeah what was there I did a voice for a Zura oh speaking of what so
you know that clip from Emmys stream that she used of me like what about your cock
like oh my god my voice is cracked because I've been doing a lot of voices so that
was from I was testing my microphone for recordings I think for the game because
I didn't use the we didn't use the 3D os to record the game lines and so I was
just like fucking around and I was just like what about your cock yeah and I
would like go high and like do so she cut specifically those lines and use
because I would I would just say normal lines like oh we got to go fight these
monsters blah blah blah blah blah and then and then but then I would like
usually when I sent my line because I would send my lines to the group chat so
they could like so I could be like oh what do you guys think and then I would
usually throw in something funny at the end like for one of them oh my god I'll
just play one for you hold on let me find it because a Zura was said I sounded
like a lead character and so I recorded a league lead character lines for her
there is it well me what are you doing oh yeah I saw she said I sounded like
Timo so I recorded Timo lines for her and she was geeking out
tell them I turn this off real brief like
size doesn't mean everything never underestimate the power of the scouts
code swiftly I didn't even know the voice that I can do sounds like Timo
cuz I don't play league ow I just hit my arm so it was like really funny and I
let me see if I can find the one I set let me find the one that I am that that
came from let me see this one that's not it wait was it cuz yeah it was the it
was also like the trailer lines that we were working on for the for the for the
trailer that was a mutual no no it's not really
peachy no I don't think that sounds really peachy at all that was almost my
line for the trailer hard hard because the editor kept sending like for the
video first like when they sent in the lines my mic would always peak for the
work hard so that's why I didn't make it into the trailer cuz I'm like hard and
it just sounded like shit but first but when I play it back it sounds normal so
I'm like huh brother and they're editing that's fucking up my audio because I
really like to work hard play harder I want to hear boomy I have I have some
bloopers from me do recording some naughty stuff I'll play them for you
you can hear him go in the background that was actually yeah I was behind the
scenes for the the thing that was released can I do stitch I'd have to
listen to stitch voice I'm trying to find specifically the one that Amy used
where is it well this one's called giggles nefariously I just label stuff
random oh strongy asked me this she's like can you send me some of your giggles
I sent her some giggles oh Hanna oh Hanna oh yeah I can't do it right now
I might be guys like the ASMR what's this one this one's called get bread what
is this oh that's from a an audio you guys can't hear that he he he get that
bread Gregory you guys can't hear stuff can you do it evil lioness from the
lion king ever got her name like Shiva something
oh this one
that's something stupid at the end it's not easy being cheesy can you make a
drawing of me of course you can I love fan art Zira I haven't heard Zira's
voice in a very long time I would have to listen to that do-do-do I'm like so
determined to find this
not not not
this one's called Tee he I really labeled everything so well
you
like at me on the background as I'm like doing you're kissing
oh
oh yeah this is actually a funny one hold on accidentally fucking loop this she's
like oh wow yeah reina likes to sing the song of her people very often especially
she'll like just go into my closet and just scream for some reason I don't know
why she does that
no that's not the one I
damn it I had a muted so you guys didn't even hear what I was playing
hold on I'm being a goofball you hear the bloopers
I did it twice on accident
accidentally deleted some
you wrote maybe I need my special playtime I'll get you to fuck me with my
toys huh giggles I have a couple I have a couple bloopers and then like I would
just like mess up a line or again like so scrawny has written some of the
scripts that I read for patreon and she is bad at typing English I would have
in the sweetest I love her to death but in the sweetest way possible sometimes
unlike she this is a Scottish ism that she's put into the script but yeah it's
a little it's a little bit of behind the scenes for you I can't find the clip
that Emmy used but it was it was pretty funny I think it was another trailer
like me taking things for trailers
get the game out of here the Scots the Scots hi you're bloody we do in there
oh what huh oh no
now I was literally actually gonna end stream after that but I can yet for like
much longer thank you for the raid in me was the hello I we ended the ASMR cuz I
did ASMR and I whispered for quite some time no you're good you didn't know I've
been streaming for a streamed some extra time don't worry about it don't worry
about it not a problem at all I'm not gonna end I'll stream for longer
again now this is just an excuse for me to talk to everybody for longer you're
stuck with me you're even strong oh you know I could actually just pass you guys
off to straw me you missed it yes I'm sorry you did and the Vaude might be
nuked because although I know somebody probably archived it but there was some
very sassy things that were going on oopsies and that wasn't even me with my
full power let's just say I did way worse than what you did in me the archive I
don't think will appear anywhere until I end stream as we if strong is still
streaming if she's still streaming I didn't make people cry I slipped I did
fall down some stairs at one point that was pretty funny that was quite funny
that's me see I have to go in and change some stuff around I hate she is
still streaming what I I generally hate redirects on YouTube in the worst way
she's always streaming Mike does the woman eat yeah we're gonna raid her
because I'm EP although it's only eight but I'll probably chill out I might watch
Mad Max because I watched a gorilla Godzilla minus one yesterday did it
just stay stay stay unless you're going to straw me stream already before I can
do the redirect because it takes me 5,000 years stay good boy
that the lot the law oh how the fuck do I redirect oh no where is it me I've
only ever redirected from oh it's under this I hate okay I'll leave you click
the pencil yeah I know that I leave you with that burp farewell I figured it
out have a good night hope you enjoyed my asmr I'll probably do a more tame one
next time so give feel free to give suggestions and mirrors tame it asmr
okay okay much love much love well no fuck you I'm dominant remember fuck
you're a bitch step on you this is me punching you yeah my head hold on wait
hold on I have a better idea I hit you with my my hit my my hair fist punches
her back mods beat his ass he just punched me you don't punch me I'm the one
who punches